[Music]
what
imagine going to the doctor for a
routine checkup and discovering that you
have six months to live would you worry
about that part and ticket you got last
week would you make plans for retiring
once you reach the legal age now imagine
that seven billion people the entire
population on earth suddenly discover
that they have a few weeks or months to
live
will they worry about endangered species
global warming or terraforming the Moon
why even entertain such an unlikely
scenario extinction never happens to us
extinction always happens to someone
else to a future generation indeed
it never happens at all just when all is
lost hope grows in the belly of a woman
nevertheless many prophets have
predicted the end of man and their
predictions never came true we're still
here so why should you listen to yet
another boy who cries wolf and why am i
raising the issue of extinction in a
series that deals with physics isn't
this a subject more appropriate for
biology or paleontology it turns out
that relativist futurologists and their
allies the economists have incorporated
extinction within their respective
fields the scholars proclaim that
statistics prove that man will live
forever
the experts argue that exponential
development of technology will enable
humans first to evolve into post humans
then to build starship and colonize a
universe extinction takes man by
surprise because in spite of forewarning
no one really believes that such a
catastrophe can happen to an intelligent
species therefore it is imperative to
determine whether the mathematicians are
just daydreaming out loud if you know
that you are terminally ill you may not
want to postpone your dreams until the
last minute it's supposed to make a list
of all things we want to do in our lives
before the gripper bug cutesy madness
now we can do this I don't claim to know
the last day an hour in which the last
human will die I will merely argue that
man is terminally ill let's start with
the objective facts what is it that a
living creature needs to stay alive well
it needs essentially three ingredients
air water and food a human can live
without air for a few minutes without
water a few days and without food at
most a few weeks of the three vital
inputs food is the scarcest largely
because we produce it upon demand
what you may not be particularly aware
of is that it wasn't always so for over
100 thousand years man lived under a
stable natural economy one that consists
entirely of food in the wild an
individual procures food directly a
little over ten thousand years ago we
began to domesticate plants and animals
and to trade our surpluses for the first
time many individuals no longer obtained
food directly about 200 years ago we
experienced a revolution in
manufacturing machinery made farming so
efficient that labourers were no longer
needed in such high numbers people
migrated to the cities and agriculture
became an ever smaller proportion of the
global economy the manufacturing phase
lasted a fraction of the agricultural
phase we quickly developed a service
sector and displaced both agriculture
and manufacturing today food constitutes
only 4% of man's global economy and
manufacturing a mere 30 percent will
this trend continued until the global
economy consists entirely of services if
not when will it stop let's run all that
buy again and fast forward to get the
big picture for over 100,000 years food
constituted 100% of man's economy there
was roughly a 10 to 1 ratio between
hunted and hunter then in the last
10,000 years men gradually at first and
exponentially more recently distance
himself from food in a parallel
development we went from sparsely
populated villages to densely populated
towns and cities in a geologically brief
interval of time humans don't live
evenly spread out across the earth
humans are distributed like ants one ant
hole here another one there urbanization
results in density dependent births
rates the global population is now
guaranteed to grind to a halt
one day unfortunately man's artificial
economy cannot survive on a constant or
declining population sales are founded
on the principle that there will be more
demand next year so what does the
we have to do with extinction the basic
ecological pyramid consists of three
trophic levels primary production
herbivores and carnivores a stable
healthy pyramid has roughly attend to
one ratio between these levels the mass
of the higher level is roughly one-tenth
of the mass of the next level the
natural world is an inefficient wasteful
world much food goes unconsumed and
simply rots away man's artificial
economy cannot run on such an
inefficient ten to one ratio efficiency
demands that we produce food practically
upon demand but who produces food and
for what reasons the vast majority of
food in the world is produced and
distributed by agricultural corporations
food is just another business and
corporations produce it for profits what
we have done in the last 100,000 years
gradually at first and exponentially
more recently is overturn our ecological
pyramid the argument for extension is
simple no profits no food one dark day
global economy descended rates first
thousands then millions worldwide are
laid off in a self feeding cycle of
increasing unemployment and decreasing
consumer spending overnight money loses
its value and the agricultural
corporations have no further incentives
to produce or distribute food the mobs
have emptied the supermarket shelves the
delivery trucks have not arrived in
weeks
you soul only consume your last can of
tuna now what what will you exchange for
food when food is the only thing that
has any value you may argue that this
bleak scenario is impossible mans
fantastic artificial economy cannot just
vanish overnight can it the facts show
otherwise our economists have
popularized the misleading notion that
business comes in cycles we've been
through recessions and depressions
before and miraculously recovered what's
different this time around is that we no
longer have a manufacturing economy
the long-term economic trend is not
cyclical as the economists would have
you believe but linear we never return
to hunter-gathering and we never went
back from manufacturing to agriculture
and we certainly won't go back from
services to manufacturing The
Economist's are fools that they predict
that a constant or declining population
will thrive under a service regime for
the next million years in fact now one
expert out there can tell you how the
service sector intends to create jobs
everyone merely extrapolates trends and
tells you that the economy is somehow
going to recover in the past governments
were able to stimulate agriculture and
manufacturing by putting people to work
in labor-intensive jobs today we use
sophisticated machines to do agriculture
roadwork and manufacturing if the
government sent millions of unemployed
to the farms and factories the
corporation's would send the masses
marching right back the day our global
economy disintegrates every person on
earth from Bill Gates to Bill Goethe is
suddenly unemployed that they you
instantly become a hunter but what else
is there to hunt in the urban jungle out
there if not another human widespread
starvation coupled with rampant
cannibalism among top predators is what
guarantees the exponential decrease of
their population a mass extinction is
not the result of nuclear war disease or
extraterrestrial impacts a mass
extinction is by definition a
catastrophic economic collapse it occurs
when the ecological pyramid overturns
and the many end up chasing after the
few in the coming videos I will argue
that a mass extinction is an inevitable
natural process which politicians and
economists intelligence and technology
can do nothing about and if humans
cannot avoid their own extinction in
spite of their magical ability to
foresee events neither could any other
species of plants or animals in the
history of life on Earth
Oh
[Music]
Oh
[Music]